the world's first 3d photo printing
booth gives you the chance to become
your own action figure and Los Angeles
proudly presents $500 caviar from a
vending machine Vsauce Kevin here this
is mind blow a graduate from Design
Academy Eindhoven created a set of
cutlery designed to stimulate more than
just your sense of taste synesthesia is
a neurological condition in which
different stimuli such as touch taste
and hearing are affected and triggered
by each other the different pieces
explore the effects of color and various
textures on the senses red colors are
supposed to increase the appetite and
various textures and shapes are intended
to stimulate the sense of touch inside
the mouth with the intention of
enriching the eating experience
scientists at MIT have created a tiny
transformer the millimole team is a
reconfigurable robot that can be
programmed to fold itself into a number
of different shapes another breakthrough
with this robot is that after it has
shifted into a new shape it can hold
that shape even when its power is cut
off by using what they call an electro
permanent motor they do say that there
would need to be a lot of research as
well as cheaper more durable parts
before a real live transformer is
created ski dome Denmark is a vision of
the world's biggest ski dome in the city
of Randers Denmark designed by a Danish
architecture firm the proposal includes
over three kilometres of indoor and
outdoor slopes a freestyle park hotel
restaurant and shops resembling a
snowflake the structure consists of
three centrally connected arches that
each span the river each arch also uses
its roof exterior to connect the city
beyond skiing such as the bottom arch
having a rooftop of green landscape that
would function as a raised city park
who's hungry for a solid chocolate baby
had speaking of chocolate Cadbury
invented its own melt resistant
chocolate that stays solid even when
left at 104 degrees Fahrenheit for three
and it has to do with breaking the sugar
particles into smaller pieces reducing
the amount of fat covering them making
it more resistant to heat the sea
explorer 5 aims to give people a chance
to finally own a luxury submarine for
2.4 million dollars you get seating for
five air conditioning an audio system
LED lighting and enough air food and
water for up to 96 hours in the off
chance you lose power made by you Boat
Works there website boasts that it's the
world's first subsea limousine and
features a 360 degree acrylic pressure
hull so everyone has a view the
first-ever picture of tightly packed
cords of DNA taken with an electron
microscope little grass is bringing
books back to the physical world by
printing them on t-shirts the first four
designs are Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland on the Origin of Species The
Great Gatsby and Moby Dick
the shirts contain all or most of the
book depending on the size and the text
is completely legible they've already
exceeded their Kickstarter goal check
out the website for more created in
Japan the BFS OTO can read books at 250
pages per minute which equates to an
oxford dictionary in just 10 minutes or
an entire 32 volume set of encyclopedia
britannica in about two hours it
achieves high-definition resolution at
400 pixels per inch and can compensate
for the three-dimensional deformation of
the paper wall being flipped giving it
the ability to scan thousands of books
quickly without damaging them basically
it's like johnny-five from short circuit
finally here's a video from mie called
jammed about the demise of the audio
cassette in a story of a viewmaster
robot venturing into an unknown world
I am
I'm gonna leave you with Disney's
prototype of a humanoid robot playing
catch and as always thanks for watching